gefunden habe ich ihn auf youtube
ich bin süder pascal pascal mancini ein
schweizer der ausgestiegen ist jetzt
lebt er in einer hippie-kommune verdient
sich ein paar euros als touristenführer
mehr braucht er nicht für sein neues
leben in den bergen von analysieren
[Musik]
ich will verstehen wie das leben fernab
der normalen gesellschaft funktioniert
deswegen verbringe ich die nächsten 36
stunden mit ihm eine autostunde entfernt
von malaga der stadtarchivar irgendwo am
wegesrand treffen wir uns nicht so hoch
und runtergefahren
hier oben kommt eben ist und das navi
war total überfordert mit der gegner wir
fahren rein ins camp am eingang eine
menge wohnwagen es ist acht uhr morgens
hier schlafen noch alle
ungefähr 200 leute leben hier
das gelände wurde vor etwa 30 jahren von
einem englischen ehepaar gekauft und der
aussteiger gemeinschaft zur verfügung
gestellt jeder darf seitdem herkommen
und sich niederlassen
aber ich könnte einfach hier bleiben ob
mir das gefallen würde
es ist heiß heute fast 40 grad
die wege sind steil und beschwerlich
hier zu leben ist für manche zu
anstrengend also ich war hier vor paar
wochen und da war das zelt noch intakt
ja kein boxmeer keine kraft mehr so
schnell wie möglich nach hause zu mama
und das lässt man dann uns überlassen
was würdest du sagen wie groß ist der
anteil der leute die die aufgeben
wirklich nur vorne prozent
wahrscheinlich fünf prozent hier übrig
oder so also in geringer teil und
entweder mit selektierte der berg sich
aus oder die menschen oder du dich
selber dass cal ist seit eineinhalb
jahren hier sein leben bisher war
ziemlich facettenreich früher hat er als
bmx-fahrer geld verdient dann eine
familie gegründet einen soliden vollzeit
job gehabt jetzt job der als
touristenführer aber im moment deswegen
corona kaum jemand da wie kommt er ohne
ein geregeltes einkommen klar das ist
das erste was immer kommt auch bei mir
ich habe sie mal 1000 franken verdient
in der schweiz ein guter job aber
irgendwann bringt nichts mehr ja mein
sohn ist groß 18
und dann habe ich auch gesucht nach was
anderes der alltagstrott jeden tag brav
zur arbeit gehen das reichte ihnen nicht
mehr
er wollte mehr freiheit im internet fand
er die aussteiger community er lebt
jetzt oben in den bergen weit weg vom
trubel im eingangsbereich für um finde
ich eigentlich ziemlich ruhig und
entspannt und lehrer du merkst energien
anders das ist einfach so bezahlten
preis für deine ruhe für deinen platz
und das ist dein schweiz und die
anstrengung nach hause und alles das was
du brauchst er hoch zu tragen
nach einer guten halben stunde sind wir
dann endlich angekommen das ist pascal
haus in den letzten eineinhalb jahren
hat er sich hier stück für stück seine
herberge gebaut startkapital hat er
keins mitgebracht zum duschen hat der
frisches quellwasser die toilette ist
ein mehrere meter tiefes loch hinter dem
haus wenn der abschlussbericht ist also
nicht zumindest nicht hat jetzt angst
das ist für das gericht aber das sind
viele vorurteile das machen ja das sind
die medizinischen mariana fans sind
damals salat aus wir gießen noch die
anderen salat pflänzchen und werden
dabei ganz unbemerkt von einem anderen
camp bewohner gefilmt kevin ursprünglich
aus geislingen in baden württemberg
genau wie pascal hat er einen youtube
kanal seit der korona krise merkt er
dass sich immer mehr leute für das
aussteiger leben interessieren senkt
durch diese corona das wird gerade
hatten sehen sich die menschen von
bisher nach freiheit wir wurden alle in
unserer freiheit ein bisschen
eingeschränkt denke ich habe mir zum
ersten mal gespürt was freiheit
eigentlich wirklich bedeutet und welche
freiheiten wir vorher genommen haben und
da die so ein bisschen weggebrochen sind
wenn sich das doch ein und drang in
jedem menschen sich frei bewegen können
und auch in die natur zu gehen mit
freunden zu treffen
kevin ist begeistert vom freien leben
außerhalb vom system wie er sagt aber er
will weg von hier
seine eigene community gründen wir
wollen solche orte nochmal kopieren noch
mal neu gestalten das positive heraus
holen und kopieren das negative so ein
bisschen weglassen da ist ja doch
ziemlich ja es gibt beide teile einfach
am fuß des berges wo die wohnwagen
stehen
das ist der problembezirk im aussteiger
camp über die jahre sind viele hier
gestrandet und an der freiheit
verzweifelt drogenmissbrauch vor allen
dingen der alkohol bringt konflikte
gefilmt werden möchte hier niemand von
der bisherigen berichterstattung über
die kommune halten sie nicht viel
wir schlafen im hotel am nächsten morgen
in ort lieber ich treffe mich wieder mit
pascal wir gehen zusammen zum supermarkt
den wocheneinkauf erledigen
pascal ist kein selbstversorger sondern
versucht möglichst sparsam einzukaufen
etwa 30 euro braucht er in der woche
sagt er
normalerweise gibt es einen markt in der
stadt auf dem er sich ein bisschen was
man stand auf und abbau verdient aber
das fällt jetzt zur krone zeit weg hier
in ort gehören die hippies wie sie von
den locals immer noch genannt werden zum
stadtbild dazu viele von ihnen schlagen
sich jetzt ohne den markt von tag zu tag
durch zb als straßenmusiker spanien ist
schon lange ein beliebtes ziel für
aussteiger
es begann als die ersten hippies in den
60er jahren die inseln ibiza und
formentera für sich entdecken
das spanische festland wurde erst später
von den aussteigern erschlossen
pascal und ich laufen zurück zum kern 6
kilometer bei fast 40 grad sogar die
hunde kommen ihre grenzen
zurück bei pascals haus abendessen
vorbereiten er hat seinen nachbarn
eingeladen
peter er war früher dachdecker die
letzten zehn jahre dann hausmeister
peter kommt aus schwerte lebt jetzt seit
zwei jahren hier statt für irgendeinen
chef wollte peter endlich für sich
selbst arbeiten und für die gemeinschaft
dachte er ich hatte eigentlich erwartet
dass das zusammenleben hier besser
funktioniert ich hatte auch nicht weiter
dass ich montags auf dem feld erwartet
ging es in der küche mittwochs im stall
muss sie das ist zu sehen dass er über
die runden kommen dass alle satt wird im
grunde genommen bin ich gar nicht froh
dass es keine funktionierende kommunist
hat man mehr freiheit auch ich hatte mir
das leben in der aussteiger community
irgendwie gemeinschaftliche vorgestellt
aber ein treffen mit den anderen
bewohnern ein gesprächskreis gibt es nur
bei größeren streitereien
es ist ein freier lebensraum wo man wo
man mit anderen gleichgesinnten sich
zusammenschließt vielleicht so
die realität von peter und pascal ist
eben keine fröhliche hippie kommune
sondern ein loser zusammenschluss von
menschen die alle vor allem eines wollen
freiheit
den platz dafür gibt es hier